a sensitivity reader is hired either by  an author or by the author's publisher  to review the book specifically in terms  of how characters with certain  marginalizations or certain identity  characteristics are written and to let  the author know if they've gotten it  quote unquote right  rosenfield has first-hand experience  with the process she was once brought in  to read the novel of a male author to  verify that he had accurately portrayed  the female experience i had to imagine  myself in the position of a much more  sensitive much more easily offended  person the kind of person who reads a  book looking for something to get mad at  i was doing something fundamentally at  odds with what it means to write fiction  trying to get this man to save his own  hide by altering his book in service of  the sensibilities of people who  were never going to read it in the first  place  you